بعد عده اجتماعات عقدت على مدى الشهور
الماضيه اتفق اعضاء ما يعرف باسم الطاوله
السداسيه وهي كيان يجمع قاده ابرز سته
احزاب معارضه على تسميه كمالك رئيس حزب
الشعب الجمهوري اكبر احزاب الطاوله مرشحا
مشتركا ليخوض السباق الرئاسيه في مواجهه
الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
لا اريد الاطاله عليكم نتيجه للاجتماعات
التي عقدناها اخترنا السيد كمال
مرشحنا للرئاسه
سنقود تركيا من خلال الديمقراطيه
والمشهوره ومن خلال النظام البرلماني
المعزز زعماء الاحزاب السته سيكونون في
منصب مساعد رئيس الجمهوريه اتفقنا على
خارطه طريق من 11 ماده ضمن النظام
البرلماني المعزز
لم يكن الوصول الى هذا الاتفاق سهلا
فرئيسه الحزب الجيد ميراكشنار كانت انسحبت
من اجتماع الطاوله السداسيه معتبره انها
تحولت الى رهينه لقرار شخص واحد في اشاره
نفسه داعيه رئيسي بلديتي انقره واسطنبول
منصور واكرم امامولو المنتميين لحزبه
لتولي ما سمته المهمه التاريخيه وخوض
احدهما غمار هذه المنافسه في وجه اردوغان
لكن ما لبث الرجلان ان اقنعها لاحقا
بالعوده للطاوله
ان اطراف المعارضه فضلت ترك تحديد اسم
المرشح المشترك للنهايه وهذا ما تسبب في
تفجير الازمه في وقت حرج قد ينعكس ذلك
باثر نفسي سلبي على كتله ناخب المعارضه
ويزيد اختيار الطاوله السداسيه
مرشحا مشتركا للرئاسه من سخونه السباق
الرئاسي القادم فهو يعتبر احد ابرز الخصوم
السياسيين للرئيس التركي الحالي ولا يترك
كلجدار اوغلو بمناسبه الا ويؤكد فيها انه
سيعمل ما بوسعه لاسقاط الرئيس
بالتزامن مع تسميتي كمالك الاتجار اوغلو
مرشحا مشتركا لابرز تحالفا في المعارضه
اعلن الرئيس التركي انه سيصدر يوم الجمعه
قرارا باجراء الانتخابات في الرابع عشر من
مايو القادم ولتبدا بعد ذلك
المنافسه الانتخابيه رسميا
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره انقره